[Music]
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
the riddler is asking for you the killer
left this for the batman why is he
writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
there's latest it's all about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this oh you're really
not as smart as i thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
lied to me alfred
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know he's up to
delaney
where are you under there
what are you hiding selena i'll throw
your life away don't worry honey i got
nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it through violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we could
see
and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ellie
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
figure why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
your reputation precedes you
have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting two versus what he's gotta be
kidding
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
[Music]
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
[Music]
your desecration of reality
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
what's a better soldier you're my dad
careful
come on let's go did you actually see my
dad's wife yes
we looked after each other i like
brothers
yeah kind of like brothers
james the cleaning house
you're leaving the army with an
honorable discharge but you're losing
your pension and health care
we gave them our minds our bodies and
our spirit
and they'd shoot us up and spit us out i
just want to check in with y'all on your
past due payment message deleted what
you did in uniform sledgehammer [ __ ]
our thing scalpel work
we operate a deep black og offshoot with
direct presidential authority
bank some decent cash put a down payment
on the house
that's not dangerous now i know you're
lying maybe i need to take care of my
family so what do you say you're down
for the cause yeah
salim mohammed mosu
study pathogenic influenza viruses in
humans
we all know what one motivated radical
can do
so let's cowboy up get it done and get
home to our families you don't
understand what you're doing i'm trying
to save lives
this is only about money
what did we do mike
i've got an extraction team brown bmw x1
comply i'll do that when you confirm who
you're working for you work for me
you gotta trust me i am trying to help
you oh we're working for the president
of corporations
they train us to run their errands
kill their enemies and kill each other
it's easy to kill but it's much harder
to survive
need to get back home
home's in memory
[Music]
going to come after you with everything
he's got
[Music]
i'm going home
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you
tales okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drinking
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
mcmahon you do know you're not dash
right dash is a character i made up
oh my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
sage is missing i'm going to rescue her
i just want her to think of me as more
than a cover model that stands even
dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm sort
of like crossfit
i snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that get out
of there this is not a romance novel
jungles eat people like us what is that
get it off
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh
oh
oh
loretta sage getting you out of here why
are you so handsome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
[Music]
the germans must be coming he can smell
them
who the red ghost
they say he sent 100 crowds to meet
their maker
who has seen the red ghost
maybe he's immortal
and get ready for a battle
try
grenade
[Music]
it's our chance maybe our only hope
this is my home
just tell us your name
hello
come
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline in the
universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
a hero
i just got goosebumps
[Music]
if we don't stand up no one will
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
every night i dream about that strange
city like his calling
the target is a writer his book is
titled godslayer and the writer's name
is conglent my boss is convinced that
what happens in the story is somehow
affecting his health you only have three
days you don't want to let us down
he's no mortal like
you well you're the one writing it so
you can decide what happens next
i come to kill you
show yourself
you're going up against powers beyond
your comprehension you don't even stand
a
the chance not done
i have to finish it
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly
i have increased strength and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of him
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
uh dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
not doing anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
what's that
power you said it was clear i said the
front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen
we have to stop that getting onto the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons the
billionaire armstealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie star rick simmons favorite
movie sir and how do we get him
blackmail
who's together
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager
there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
just down here you made that coin
evident when marimba rhythms start to
play i need to be nervous
no reason to be nurse
they're all the killers
you're an actor act
okay
i'm ready
let's go to work will someone pinch me
please is that danny francesco what's
next for dude i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire you just described
me
shadow mate do whatever i do
whatever i do do
whoever greg was flying from was amongst
you last night dear friends
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
they're gonna kill you now we'll shoot
them first
that is a sexy name cover's blown we're
burnt what do i do the emergency is
going to melt
you stopped daddy francesco you stopped
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
does yes
yes
now
behold
he's here
he's here
father is here the kingman lady the king
your fake is sick and you cannot escape
it
now i've missed you my son
one day this kingdom will be yours
thank you father
my king
[Music]
father
remember
[Music]
why would he throw away to such a
hellish place
to find what was stolen from me
and what is that
the kingdom
you must choose between kindness for
your give
or hate for your enemies
your strength breaks man's bones
[Applause]
i have the calling to break their minds
and night by night we will carry out my
pledge of
vengeance now i'm killing your feelings
we all understand betrayal some of us
are with a system maybe it was our
families could have been a stranger
nothing i love more than watching grown
men squeal
[Music]
we are men we founded this country on
our backs now they want us to give up
power willingly into the hands of people
who are incapable of wielding it
over my dead
body
[Applause]
[Music]
what are we doing kind of like a pain at
the streets program
look i don't smack you in the mouth i'd
like to see you trying
there's some feminists who want to
attack my event
i need additional protection
she's going to be in the body bag before
sundown
no one's going to give it to us so we
have to take
the violence you know it's gonna come
back to you it always does
you guys are professional murderers
coming from your blood remember boys be
nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't make it easy
you got a minute oh what
whoa
when how did she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too okay
so what are you doing here
i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
and um okay we'll go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets but they're stronger than
you think the mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestructible
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
[Music]
sorry
you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
which is which is crazy i didn't even
know that was a thing but it's like a
dog water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k9g what is a k-9
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
[Music]
i'm here because we need your help
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evelyn's
you can access all the memories their
emotions
even their skills
there's a great evil spreading the many
verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
ah that looks really good
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of senseless things is so much
bigger
than you realize
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
multiverse
there is no way i am the everlane you
are looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you